بعد انتهاء انتخابات التجديد النصفيه في
نوفمبر الماضي بدا الطريق الى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه لعام 2021
يرسم مساره الوجهه لا تزال ضبابيه وسط
اعلان البعض عزمهم حوض غمار السباق الى
البيت الابيض فيما ينتظر عدد من المرشحين
اللحظه المناسبه لكن اللافت الصراع الدائر
داخل البيت الواحد للدقه اكثر بين اعضاء
الحزب الجمهوري الذين تعبوا اصواتهم واحدا
تلو الاخر انتقادا وتحديدا لرئيس الامريكي
السابق وفي اشد الانتقادات حتى الان
للترامب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك الذي قال ان
التاريخ سيحاسب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ترامب على دوره في الهجوم على مبنى
الكونجرس في السادس من يناير
وفي التفاصيل انتقادات ماكس ليست وليده
الساعه وتعود لحادثه الكبد فتعود ليوم
اقتحم الالاف من انصار مبنى الكونجرس في
محاوله لمنع ماركنس من التصديق على نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2020 والتي
خسرها ترامب كان مايك بينز داخل مبنى
الكابيتون لكنه كانت مهمته الدستوريه
كنائب رئيس هو التصديق على نتائج
الانتخابات وهو ما رفضه انصار ترامب الذين
هاتفوا اشنقوا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن داخل الحزب الجمهوريه في الولايات
المتحده لم يكن مارك بانس وحده في وجه
الانتقادات
فحاكمه ولايه سابقين
انتقدت في وقت سابق سلوكه في الهجوم على
مبنى الكابيتول من قبل انصاره وقالت ان
افعاله منذ يوم الانتخابات سيحكم عليها
تاريخ وبقسوه الى ذلك ايضا وجه انتقادات
مبطنه الى رئيسه السابق مجادلا بان البلاد
بحاجه الى قاده جديد لا يقضون وقتهم
بالتفكير في تويتر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]